[Musique]
le maire du chesnay rocancourt richard
delpierre a fait appel de la décision du
tribunal administratif d'annuler
l'élection municipale du 15 mars dernier
le recours avait été déposé par son
prédécesseur et adversaire lors des
municipales philippe brillault de
nouvelles élections pourraient être
organisées si cet appel est rejeté par
le conseil d'état auprès duquel la
sphère a été confiée huit centres de
dépistage sont déployés à proximité des
gares dignoise des tests anti génie qui
sont réalisés pour des résultats
communiqués en une vingtaine de minutes
les centres garde saint quentin en
yvelines et versailles chantiers sont
déjà effectifs un marché virtuel de
saint quentin en yvelines c'est la
promesse de l'application shop in sky
les commerçants des douze communes de
l'agglomération pourront s'y inscrire
gratuitement les clients commanderont
les produits sur l'application pour les
récupérer en magasin afin de favoriser
les commerces locaux
la protection maternelle et infantile
fête ce mois ci ses 75 ans assurant la
promotion de la santé de l'enfant et de
sa famille la médecine qui est effectué
et préventive gratuit pour les femmes
enceintes et les enfants jusqu'à 6 ans
les centres pmi sont au nombre de 23
dans les yvelines les possessions
tension activité ces dernières semaines
le nombre de colis est actuellement de
28 % plus élevé que ce qui était prévu
sur le circuit nor des yvelines cela
représente 35 mille colis par jour
traitées
une hausse qui va entraîner le
recrutement de 30 personnes pour
supporter le black friday et noël
[Musique]